die ebola solche hat sich zu einem
umfangreichen outbreak entwickelt den
letzten tagen hat diese entwicklung auf
pixum de die meldung beherrscht deshalb
heute die top five - ausschließlich news
zum thema apple an
720 siebter 2014 im
bevölkerungsreichsten land afrikas ist
jetzt der ebola virus entdeckt worden in
nigeria ist ein mann aus liberia nach
dem feststellen der infektion mit dem
virus gestorben
in liberia guinea wie auch in sierra
leone gezielt der ebola virus ja bereits
experten hatten schon im vorfeld mit
einer weiteren ausbreitung berechnet
zudem haben sich auch einer der
führenden virologen scheich omar khan
angesteckt und ein amerikanischer arzt
an der rettung der beiden mediziner wird
mit maximalem einsatz gearbeitet
dasselbe gilt selbstverständlich auch
für alle anderen infizierten die beiden
experten hatten sich trotz umfangreicher
sicherheitsvorkehrungen angesteckt
leider infizieren sich immer mehr ärzte
und helfer
zudem wird derzeit nach einer
infizierten in sierra leone gesorgt die
von ihren verwandten aus dem krankenhaus
entführt wurde
sie könnte weitere personen anstecken
das große problem viele der afrikaner
halten sich aufgrund eigener tradition
nicht an die vorgegebene distanz zu
infizierten oder toten die andauernde
ausbreitung des ebola-virus seit ende
märz bereitet weltweit sorge zwar gibt
es entwarnung für eine verbreitung der
erreger auf andere kontinente mit der
weiteren ausbreitung in afrika wird
allerdings gerechnet die organisation
ärzte ohne grenzen schickt weiterhin
hilfe nach westafrika um die situation
zu verbessern
29 siebter 2014 damit sich der ebola
virus nicht weiter ausbreitet schließt
liberia die grenzen weitestgehend nach
außen und innen ab so soll verhindert
werden dass liberianer sich anstecken
oder die krankheit ins ausland
übertragen man versuche die verbreitung
des erregers zu stoppen
mit der schließung der grenzen gegen die
vae ja so einen ersten wichtigen schritt
grund ist unter anderem die übertragung
der krankheit nach nigeria ein liberaler
war nach einem flug in das
bevölkerungsreichste land afrikas
zusammengebrochen und im krankenhaus
positiv auf ebola getestet worden
er verstarb jetzt das beste wäre wenn
niemand mehr krank reisen würde aber
eine krankheit würde niemand bei einer
reise zu geben sagt dr
david hyman von der london school of
hygiene
and tropical medicine und genau das sei
das problem des weiteren hat liberias
präsidentin ellen johnson-sirleaf eine
task force gebildet sie ruft dazu auf
gemeinsam gegen den virus vorzugehen
mittlerweise ist es eine krise die 129
menschen allein in liberia getötet hat
am anfälligsten für eine infektion mit
dem gefährlichen virus sind die
verwandten der kranken die in direktem
kontakt zu den infizierten standen zudem
sind auch die ärzte und pfleger der
krank in akuter gefahr sich anzustecken
erst kürzlich hatte sich ein
amerikanischer arzt infiziert
mittlerweile ist jeder leone das zentrum
der krankheit das meldet die
hilfsorganisation ärzte ohne grenzen
seit der ersten entdeckung der erreger
im turnier sind bislang 1093
krankheitsfälle und 660 tote gemeldet
worden
das ist der stand vom 24 juni 30 ist er
siebter 2014 schalko mag an einer der
bedeutendsten ebola experten in afrika
vor wenigen stunden gestorben
der führende virologe erlag multiplen
organversagen verursacht durch das
ebola-virus der englische twitter
account von ärzte ohne grenzen
verbreitete die meldung bei los auf drk
mauer patients and medical college
inspirational nr
laut unbestätigten berichten sollte in
hamburg behandelt werden vorher erlag er
allerdings der infektion er starb in
einem krankenhaus im norden series wenig
tage nachdem er sie infiziert hatte
sein tod ist ein herber rückschlag im
kampf gegen die ebola epidemie in
westafrika zudem ist der fall ein
erschreckendes zeichen dafür dass ebola
doch ansteckender ist als bisher
vermutet immer mehr krankenschwestern
und ärzte fallen der seuche zum opfer
die folge könnte eine schwindende
bereitschaft seien in krankenhäusern zu
arbeiten in denen ebola opfer behandelt
31 ist siebter 2014 die ebola solche
greift immer weiter um sich
inzwischen gelten ganzer regionen als
betroffen liberias präsidentin ellen
johnson-sirleaf hat jetzt den notstand
erklärt die mehrheit der
staatsbediensteten wurden in einen
30-tägigen zwangsurlaub beordert um die
ausbreitung des ebola virus zu stoppen
die grenzen des landes wurden ja bereits
weitestgehend geschlossen wie wir
berichtet
der kommende freitag also der erste
august 2014 wurde zu einem ferientag
erklärt um sämtliche schulen zu
desinfizieren
die schulen sollen so lange geschlossen
bleiben bis die ansteckungsgefahr
drastisch gesenkt wurde ebenso werden
die märkte in den grenzregionen
geschlossen um nicht für eine weitere
verbreitung der erreger zu sorgen die
liberianische regierung hat zudem
sämtliche großveranstaltungen untersagt
die afrikanischen fluglinien strichen
ihre flüge und der liberianische fußball
verband hat seine spiele in der nahen
zukunft abgesagt die präsidentin ellen
johnson sirleaf kündigte darüber hinaus
ein notprogramm zur bekämpfung von ebola
an fünf millionen dollar wie sie dafür
bereitstellen mittlerweile sind mehr als
1300 menschen in westafrika infiziert
worden mehr als 700 von ihnen sind
bereits gestorben
probleme bereiten nach wie vor die
familien die die kranken nicht behandeln
lassen und verstecken
doch auch in den medizinischen
hilfsstation von ärzte ohne grenzen und
anderen hilfsorganisationen ist keine
komplette sicherheit mehr vor dem virus
gewährleistet denn immer mehr helfer und
ärzte stecken sich an deshalb haben die
usa bereits hunderte freiwillige des us
friedenskurs abgezogen
in europa wurde zunächst entwarnung
gegeben experten gehen davon aus dass
der aggressive ebola erreger nicht nach
europa gelangen können dennoch gab es in
großbritannien einen ersten
verdachtsfall der glücklicherweise nicht
bestätigt werden konnte die regierungen
sind allerdings in alarmbereitschaft
das virus das durch körperflüssigkeiten
übertragen wird ist derzeit noch nicht
mit medikamenten behandelbar jedoch kann
der den patienten bei frühzeitiger
erkennung der krankheit geholfen werden
und die tödlichen symptome werden
reduziert so dass die infizierten
überleben können
zweiter achter 2014 der ebola outbreak
hat stattgefunden
während jedes bisherige auftreten der
solche lokal stark beschränkt war ist
jetzt das furchtbare passiert ebola
stellt jeden bisherigen fall in den
schatten und überschreitet immer mehr
grenzen
der ebola outbreak ist jetzt komplett
außer kontrolle geraten inzwischen ist
die solche sogar über den flugverkehr
verbreitet worden womit am anfang
eigentlich niemand gerechnet hat ein
ebola infizierter ist nach einem flug
aus liberia in den idealen stadt lagos
eine großstadt am flughafen
zusammengebrochen und danach gestorben
dabei hat er wohl mindestens zwei
menschen infiziert die jetzt in nigeria
auf einer isolierstation liegen 69
weitere menschen mit denen er kontakt
hatte stehen unter beobachtung
damit hat die solche gezeigt welche
fatalen auswirkungen sie hat wenn sie in
dicht besiedeltes gebiet genannt in
nigeria wird jetzt befürchtet dass sich
die seuche auch in lagos und dann in
ganz nigeria ausbreitet nachdem
monatelang von keiner gefahr für reisen
in die betroffenen länder ausgegangen
worden war hat das auswärtige amt jetzt
eine reisewarnung ausgegeben also es
wird davor gewarnt nach liberia sierra
leone und guinea zu reisen
das außenamt geht davon aus dass eine
ausbreitung der krankheit nicht
auszuschließen ist in liberia ist
derweil die armee ausgerückt um panik
tumulte zu verhindern
die schlimmsten befürchtungen sind auch
wahr geworden was die zahl der
todesopfer betrifft laut aktuellen
zahlen vom 27 juli sind in den drei
tagen zuvor 27 57 menschen an ebola
gestorben das sind knapp 10
der gesamt toten bisher damit hat sich
das tempo der ausbreitung in den letzten
wochen verdreifacht
auch die zahl der gestorbenen helfer
wurde inzwischen bekannt gegeben es sind
60 ärzte krankenschwestern und weitere
hilfe an der seuche gestorben was zeigt
dass das ebola fieber im gegensatz zu
bisherigen annahmen viel ansteckender
ist als vermutet zudem wird die
bekämpfung der solche damit weiter
behindert wenn die helfer bei der
behandlung sterben
die weko hat jetzt reagiert und 100
millionen dollar note programm
aufgestellt am 6 august www jetzt
beschließen
also die weltgesundheitsorganisation
dass sie sich bei dem auto um eine
gesundheitliche
auflage von internationaler tragweite
handelt was weitere gegenmaßnahmen gegen
die ausbreitung der seuche ermöglicht
werden dessen wurden zwei infizierte in
die usa ausgeflogen um sie dort besser
behandeln zu können
auch an der hamburger universitätsklinik
steht eine spezialstation bereit um
infizierte aufzunehmen in den usa
befürchtet die bevölkerung allerdings
dadurch die solche dort einzuschleppen
alles zum thema findet ihr in dieser
playlist hier klicken und täglich
informationen findet ihr im special zum
thema ebola im blog hier bei pixum de
dafür dortigen allerdings auch in der
video beschreibung und was meint ihr
wenn die entwicklung der letzten monate
wenn er die anschaut werden die behörden
den ausbruch unter kontrolle bekommen
oder wird die solche auch noch mehr
länderübergreifend diskutiertes in den
kommentaren
bis dann bleibt dran